[MUSIC PLAYING]
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-Developing a successful
app isn't easy.
To reach a broad
audience, you'll
need to consider your iOS,
Android, and mobile web users.
And to build for
these platforms,
you'll need a backend
server to store data
and support the apps.
Of course, you'll want to
get your users logged in,
hopefully lots of users,
which means your backend
will have to scale.
Then after you've solved
your scaling problems,
you'll have to find more
ways to spread the word
to get new users.
And have you found a way to
measure all this activity?
And oh no, your app is
crashing and causing
service to melt down, and you
haven't even made a dime yet.
Don't you wish this
could be easier?
This is why we built Firebase.
It has all the tools you need
to build a successful app.
It helps you reach new
users, keep them engaged,
scale up to meet that demand,
in addition to getting paid.
From the beginning,
with Firebase,
you'll have Test Lab
and Crash Reporting
to prevent and diagnose
errors in your app.
Your backend
infrastructure problems
are solved with our real
time database, file storage,
and hosting solutions.
Acquiring new users is
easy with invites, AdWords,
and dynamic likes.
And using the
authentication component,
you can get those users logged
in with minimal friction.
Once installed, you
can keep your users
engaged with notifications,
cloud messaging, and app
indexing.
Then, with remote config,
you'll have the freedom
to experiment with new
features and optimize the user
experience in real time.
And of course,
you can earn money
with the same AdMob
component that's been
monetized great apps for years.
Last, but certainly not
least, our all new analytics
component, designed
uniquely for Firebase,
brings insight into how
well these components are
working for you and your users.
With Firebase analytics,
you can measure and optimize
your advertising
campaigns, discover
who are your most
valuable users,
and understand exactly how
they are using your app.
Now all these components
work great on their own
and provide a solid
infrastructure
to build out your app,
but they work even better
when combined in creative ways.
So let Firebase handle
the details of your app's
backend infrastructure, user
engagement, and monetization,
while you spend
more time building
the apps your users will love.
To get started right
now with Firebase
on Android, iOS, or the
web, follow these links
for more information.
Then, to manage and monitor
your apps connected to Firebase,
there's a web console
to view crashes,
set up experiments, track
analytics, and a whole lot
more.
And to learn more about Firebase
and all of its components,
you can read the
documentation right here.
We can't wait to
see what you build.
[END PLAYBACK]
MARTIN OMANDER: Welcome to this
"Ask Firebase" live Hangout.
Last year after Google's
Developer Conference I/O,
we ran a live Hangout
about Android Marshmallow,
which was one of the big
announcements at I/O 2015.
Last week, Google ran I/O 2016.
And one of the
biggest announcements
there was Firebase.
Firebase is a set of
tools and infrastructure
that you as a developer can
use to improve your apps
and build your business.
As a matter of fact,
I've used it quite a bit
already to become a better dad.
I'm working together with my
son on a game that is using
a lot of Firebase services.
And it's been a great
father-son bonding experience.
But enough about me.
Let's talk about you.
You are one of about
4,000 developers
that is tuning in from
68 different countries
to watch today.
Thank you for joining us.
So with such an
excellent audience,
we made sure to get
you an excellent panel.
So on the panel here today to
answer your Firebase questions,
we have, on my left, Ian Barber,
a developer programs engineer
working on Firebase
here at Google.
Welcome Ian.
IAN BARBER: Thank you.
MARTIN OMANDER: Next to Ian
we have Magnus Hyttsten,
a Google Developer advocate
also working on Firebase.
Welcome.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN:
Thank you so much.
MARTIN OMANDER:
And next to Magnus
we have James Tamplin, a
Firebase cofounder and now
a Firebase product
lead at Google.
Welcome James.
JAMES TAMPLIN:
Thank you, Martin.
MARTIN OMANDER:
Can you believe it?
68 countries?
JAMES TAMPLIN: It's
pretty incredible.
MARTIN OMANDER:
Pretty incredible.
But, the key participant
in this event
is you, because the panel here
is here to answer your Firebase
questions.
And the way to ask those
questions is to tweet or make
a Google+ post and use the
hashtag #AskFirebaseLive and we
will see it.
We'll try to answer as many of
your questions as we can today.
And we may not get
through all of them.
And the ones we're not
able to get through we'll
see if we can answer
later on social media.
Before we get into
the questions though--
and I've looked at the list, and
there's a really good questions
in there-- we are going to
hear a short introduction
about what Firebase is and how
it can help you as a developer.
And James is going to
start us off on that.
Over to you James.
JAMES TAMPLIN: Firebase Martin.
So for those of you who
watched Google I/O and some
of the live streams,
this is going
to be a significantly abridged
version of my overview
of Firebase presentation.
And the idea is to get those
of you who haven't seen that
or haven't got a good
understanding of what Firebase
is a brief overview.
So let's get started.
So here at Google we think
that creating a successful app
is still too hard.
Developers like you are time
and resourced constrained.
And having you
spend time managing
a dozen different services or
building infrastructure that
isn't in your core competency
is a big distraction.
And so we think this
needs to be much simpler.
So as Martin
mentioned, I cofounded
a startup called Firebase, which
was a backend as a service.
It helped power
your app's backend
with three different features--
a real time database,
user authentication,
and hosting.
About 18 months ago,
it joined Google.
And we had 110,000
developers using Firebase.
It's since grown to
over 470,000 developers.
And over the past
18 months, we've
been working hard to turn
it from more than just
a backend as a
service into Google's
unified mobile platform.
And so a week or eight
days ago at Google I/O,
we announced a huge
expansion to Firebase.
So we moved from the
existing backend services
and we added tools to help you
improve your app's quality.
We added tools to help
you grow your app,
including acquiring
and engaging users.
And we added tools to
help you earn money.
By tying all this together, we
added a full analytics product.
So we went from these
original three features,
and now Firebase contains 15
features and integrations.
But we doing all of
this while trying
to stay true to the original
principles that Firebase had.
Firebase was known for its great
developer experience, intuitive
APIs, great documentation,
and fantastic support.
And we're continuing
all of that.
Firebase is cross-platform.
It's not just a
tool for Android.
Whether you're building
iOS, web, or Android apps,
we'll help you.
And finally, Firebase is an
integrated suite of products.
So we have one SDK.
We have one console.
We have one set of docs.
And where it makes
sense, data actually
flows between our products
to help you do more faster.
So let's dive in.
First we'll talk about
analytics, which really ties
the whole platform together.
So we've taken the
decade plus of knowledge
that Google has here
on Google Analytics,
and we've built Firebase
Analytics from the ground up.
And it's designed for apps.
Instead of page
views and sessions,
we're event and user centric.
And there's a feature
called Audience,
which you can think of
like user segments, that
helps connect the different
Firebase features.
And I'll touch on
those as we go through.
And best of all, it's
free and unlimited.
So you can send an
unlimited number of events
to Firebase Analytics,
completely free.
So let's jump into the services
that Firebase has to help you
power your app's backend.
So every app typically wants
to have an understanding
of who a user is so that they
can provide a personalized
experience.
And so that's exactly
what Firebase auth does.
We provide support
for authentication
with email and password social
provided like Facebook, Twitter
and Facebook and
Google, and also
tie into your existing auth
system for maximum flexibility.
And best of all, last
week we announced
that we have a brand new,
count of the box UI repo
that you can grab from GitHub.
And you can take it
and use it so that you
get years of
experience from Google
and you don't have to
reinvent the login flow.
Auth also ties into
our real time database.
Now if you used Firebase
before last week,
this is the feature
you're probably
most used to, the cloud
hosted, NoSQL JSON database.
So you store the data as JSON.
And when you write
to Firebase database,
it synchronizes it out
to every other client
who cares in milliseconds.
And this lets you build rich,
collaborative applications
that your end users are
really coming to expect.
It's super easy to
get started with.
But oftentimes you don't want
to store just structured JSON
data.
You want to store
more than this.
And this is actually one of
our largest feature requests.
And we heard you.
And so we're announcing
Firebase Storage.
Now Firebase Storage lets
you store images, videos,
audio files, really easily.
It also gracefully handles
poor internet connectivity.
And it's backed by
Google Cloud Storage.
So you can store
massively large files,
and you can also integrate
directly with the GCS APIs.
The final way to store
file data in Firebase
is Firebase Hosting.
So it lets you
serve static assets
if you're building a web or
a mobile web application.
It's SSL by default.
And last week we
announced that you can
now bring your own custom
domain to Firebase Hosting
completely for free.
So the last backend service
product I want to talk about
is Remote Config.
Now Remote Config gives
you service side variables
that you can modify and
that push down to your app
instantly so you can change
its behavior without having
to do a completely new deploy to
an app store or the Play Store.
So this lets you do things
like tweak your checkout flow
or provide a
different experience
to your users in India or who
are on a Samsung Galaxy S6.
And so this is a really,
really powerful feature
and we're really excited
what you do with it.
So we've taken a look
at the backend services.
Now let's take a
look at app quality.
So when your app crashes, it
really hurts your business
and it gives your users
a poor experience.
And so we've got two
features to help you.
First is Test Lab.
And we announced it at Google
I/O 2015 as Cloud Test Lab.
And we're moving
it into Firebase
as Test Lab for Android.
And so what it lets
you do is it lets
you run your application
on the most popular devices
before you push app
out into the wild.
And so it gives your
users the best experience
since we let you catch
bugs before they ship.
It will give you reports,
will give you screenshots,
and will let you run robo
tests if you haven't written
your own custom test suite.
And if you have, we'll
let you do that too.
But if you haven't caught
a bug before it ships,
we have Firebase
Crash Reporting.
Firebase Crash
Reporting lets you
see crashes and their impact.
We prioritize ones by
frequency and severity.
We let you drill down by
device, by OS, by API version.
And it's also integrating
with Firebase Analytics.
So you can tell if
a specific cohort
like those on a
particular device
or those in a
particular geography
are crashing more than others.
Finally, I want to talk about
how Firebase is integrated
not just with features
within Firebase,
but with broader Google.
So we've deeply integrated
with Google Play
and we've done things
like pass crash data
like ANRs or application
not responding through
to Firebase Crash Reporting.
And we're passing
in app purchase data
through to Firebase Analytics.
So you get a view of your
app all in one place.
Second, we integrated
with Google Cloud.
Underneath the hood, Firebase
accounts and Google Cloud
accounts are one and the same.
And that means you can easily
attach Google Cloud products
to your Firebase
app so that when
you need the full breadth
of the Cloud Platform,
it's right there
at your fingertips.
So I've covered how
you build your app.
Let's turn it over to Magnus
to see how you can grow an app.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN:
Thank you James.
Yes, so building an
app is just one part
of the entire development cycle.
You also want to be able to
grow a business from the app
that you develop.
And in order to do
that, we have the Grow
and the Earn
subsections of Firebase
where Grow contains the
user acquisition process
and reengaging users
that are using your apps.
And then Earn,
obviously you want
to monetize and be able to build
a business around your app.
So let's talk about looking
at the Grow part of this.
So one important activity
when you create an app
is to be able to share content
of your app with other people.
So you may want to
add the capability
to send a link to that
others can click on
and they get
engaged and they get
into a particular
piece of your app.
So in this case, for example
engaging into Bingo Blast.
The way that this
traditionally has worked
is that that link will bring
you over to an app introduction
page where you can select the
App Store or the Google Play
Store in order to
install the app.
The user clicks on one of
these, and then they're
being brought to
the installation
page for their app.
And once they've
installed app, they're
being brought into the
main page of the app.
This is a very bad
user experience.
So therefore we
introduced a capability
called dynamic links.
So dynamically links
enables you to create a link
that when a user clicks
on it, dynamic links will
check whether the app is
installed already or not.
If the app is not
installed, dynamic links
will reroute you to the
appropriate App Store or Google
Play property in order
to install the app.
And once the user opens up
the app for the first time,
the user will be brought to
a specific piece of content
that you have
indicated in your app.
And more than this,
you can actually
specify a specific state in
the URL, the dynamic link URL.
And that state can then
create a very personalized
context when they're being
brought into the app.
All right, so dynamic
links is a single URL
that brings the user
through this entire flow
to bring you to this
particular content.
It works across platforms.
It works on iOS as
well as Android.
And it preserves the URL state
through the entire process.
And of course it's
completely integrated
with Firebase Analytics.
So you can get lots of
data around the engagement
around these links.
So moving over to
Firebase Invites.
So Firebase Invites
allows users of your app
to invite their friends to
also engage with your app.
So in this example, if they
click on Send for example,
a list of their contacts
will be displayed.
They can select their
friends that they want
to invite to engage in the app.
And a link can be sent
out to these friends
so that they can
engage with the app.
Firebase Invites contains a drop
in widget for the app sharing
process.
It supports both SMS as well
as email invite messages
to the people that want
to engage with your app.
And it's built on dynamic links.
So should their friends
not have the app installed,
it will automatically bring them
through the app installation
process.
Another important component
of user acquisition
is the Google AdWords
piece we have in Firebase.
So Google AdWords is
integrated in Firebase
using the universal
app campaigns.
And what this is a
technology that allows
you to create ads for your app.
And these ads can
then be displayed
on many different Google
properties such as Google
Search, Google Play, YouTube,
as well as the Google Display
Network.
And this allows you to reach
billions of potential users
and display your app
in front of them.
There is also relevant
audience targeting.
So using the Google
data, we will
find the users that makes
the most sense to be
able to display your app.
And of course it
integrates with Analytics,
so you will get full conversion
data and optimization
data as part of this.
And what about reengaging users?
Well, we have a couple of
technologies in this area.
And one of them is
Firebase App Indexing.
Firebase App
Indexing lets Google
Search crawl your
app for content,
and then be able to display your
app as part of a result page
where users are
using Google Search.
So you can see here for example,
on the left hand side we have
a user searching for Kokkari.
And you can see TripAdvisor
actually showing up as a result
to that query because
TripAdvisor apparently
has data related to Kokkari.
And on the right hand
side, you can see somebody
searching for hotels in Tokyo.
And you can see the Expedia app
as well as the Booking.com app
showing up because they have
relevant information related
to hotels in Tokyo.
If you've been
developing apps, you
may be aware of Google
Cloud Messaging.
In this part of Firebase, we're
creating the next generation
version of Google
Cloud Messaging,
and it's called Firebase
Cloud Messaging.
In this part of
Firebase, we're also
introducing one more
notification feature,
Firebase Notifications.
Firebase Notifications is
a simple user interface
that lets you, in
a Firebase console,
enter notification
information that you
want to send to your users.
You can send this to any
kind of audience, an audience
based on a topic, based on
analytics data, et cetera.
And you will later
get information
about how your users engaged
with these notifications--
if they opened it, how
many actually clicked on
the information in
the notification,
et cetera, So a great way
to engage with your users.
As you can see here,
this is an example where
we have 3,874 notifications.
And 1,325 of these
notifications were opened.
And 637 of these notifications
were actually an engagement
that the user did,
actually engaging
with that notification.
So let's look at the Earn
part of Firebase that we have.
So for earning and
monetization of your ads,
we have Firebase
AdMob by Google.
Firebase AdMob allows you
to show ads in your app.
And these ads can take any
number of different formats.
For example, video ads, they
can be interstitial ads, showing
an ad across the entire screen,
or even native ads where
you have the ability to
format the ad in a way
that you think is
good for your app.
And there are lots of
apps already using this,
more than 1 million apps
is using AdMod already.
And it's completely integrated
into the Firebase SDK.
So it's easy to use right
there, available right now.
All right, so that was
growing and the earn part.
So I'll hand it over to
James to wrap this up.
JAMES TAMPLIN: Thanks Magnus.
So as you've seen, we've
walked briefly through
how you can develop
your app with Firebase.
So we have backend services
and those services that help
you improve your app's quality.
We have tools to help
you grow your user base,
including acquiring
and engaging users.
And finally we've
integrated with AdMob
to help you monetize your app.
And that's all tied together
with Firebase Analytics,
our free and unlimited
new analytics product.
So we are extremely
excited about this.
We've been working for
18 months and we've
pulled the best
of Google together
to help you succeed on mobile.
And we're excited to
take your questions.
So we're looking
forward to hearing them.
And don't forget
to check us out,
firebase.google.com, as I'm
sure you probably already have.
MARTIN OMANDER: Great.
Thank you Magnus, James.
So we're starting to see
some photos coming in
from of viewing parties.
Let's see, we have
one in New York,
I think I'm seeing
on the screen there.
That looks like the
New York office.
What more do we have?
That is Mountain View I think.
And is that also
Mountain View perhaps?
JAMES TAMPLIN: That's some
on brand chairs there.
MARTIN OMANDER:
Yeah, that's right.
We also have viewing parties
in the Google San Francisco
office.
I saw one in Vietnam.
I don't even know
what time it is there,
but thank you for
staying with us guys.
We really appreciate it.
So if you are at
a viewing party,
then please also send
us your pictures.
Put them on Twitter
or on Google+ with
the #AskFirebaseLive hashtag.
And we'll see them and
maybe show them here.
So let's dig into
questions guys.
Ready?
All right, good stuff.
So first off, we have had
three video questions actually.
The very first one is from
Dan Scott in Sudbury, Canada.
Dan, let's roll the video.
DAN SCOTT: Hey,
this is Dan Scott
from GDG Sudbury in Canada.
Big shout out to Francis
Ma for using Canadians
in his examples in the I/O
Firebase overview session.
So I build applications on
relational databases typically,
and I love the rich data
analysis over complex data
sets that you can perform
with ad hoc queries like joins
and scalar aggregate functions,
views, and that sort of thing.
But I also understand
and have been impressed
by the performance and
real time synchronization
that the Firebase datastore
offers for applications.
So on that note, it seems like
there must be some sort of path
to the best of both worlds.
Can you suggest
some best practices
for, say, synchronizing a
subset of a relational database,
like Postgres or BigQuery
with the Firebase datastore
so that we can still have
those complex data analysis
features over a rich data set
with the real time benefits
of the Firebase datastore?
Thanks so much.
Appreciate it, and looking
forward to your answer.
MARTIN OMANDER: Oh, so
synchronizing relational
databases and Firebase.
And this is actually
something that I've
been looking at as well.
Is there a way to do that James?
JAMES TAMPLIN: So if you want
to perform complex relational
carries queries on data that you
have in the Firebase database
what we recommend
doing is taking
the subset of the Firebase
database that you care about
and synchronizing that
out to what we've seen--
Elastic Search and Solr and
other datastores that are
optimized for rich querying.
And then you can run your
queries on those datastores.
And so typically you want
to just write a one sync
to those datastores.
MARTIN OMANDER: A one
way sync out, all right.
Did you have
anything to add Ian?
IAN BARBER: There's
a few options
you can take depending
on the kind of problem
you're trying to solve.
One of the ways that I've seen
people do things successfully
is actually to write
in to the real time
database for those real time
features to distribute things
out, and then
actually have a client
of that database that can
consume that information
and write it into
a relational store.
Often you'll want to do
reporting type queries which
can be heavily joined
and might want to go over
a long period of time.
But the part you using real
time is actually much smaller.
So by having a kind
of server instance,
you can connect as
a client, and you
can get those updates as
they come and write them
into your relational DB.
MARTIN OMANDER: All
right, good stuff.
I remember at the talk where
I spoke about Firebase,
somebody came up afterwards and
said, they're using Firebase,
not because it's
real time, but just
because it's so
easy to write code
to put things in the database.
And then they were asking
about, can I then move it
onto another database?
But I guess that's
what they should do.
Good stuff.
Thank you.
Our next video question is
from James Cha in [VIDEO OUT]
JAMES CHA: Hey,
James, hey Magnus.
So with apps, we like
our content fresh.
So using something like
Firebase to do that
makes it really easy.
But there must be some use case
where Firebase isn't the best
tool to use.
Can you describe one
of those situations?
JAMES TAMPLIN:
Haven't read it yet.
MARTIN OMANDER: All
right, up to date data.
James, is this something
you want to take on?
JAMES TAMPLIN: I'm just
catching up on the question now.
Oh, having up to date
data is something
that's important to many
if not all applications.
So is there is a use where the
Firebase real time database
wouldn't be the answer?
So typically, use cases
where the Firebase real time
data wouldn't be the
answer is where you
want to have complex querying.
So we've optimized
the Firebase database,
as Martin was mentioning,
for ease of use
and for those real time updates.
When we started, it had a
minimal set of querying.
We've met adding
to that over time.
As I mentioned in my
announcement post last week,
we're continuing to work hard
on improving the querying set
with the real time database.
But if you really need
to do complex joins
between multiple
tables, then that
is not a great use
for the real time
database at this point in time.
MARTIN OMANDER: Great.
Thank you James.
Magnus?
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: So
sometimes I even think,
I mean looking at a database
and what to store in a database,
I almost feel
sometimes that it s
accurate to describe
the Firebase real time
database as a database.
To a large extent, it's a
sharing and collaboration tool
across devices, which
typically does not
exist in a classical database.
So it really extends beyond
the classical database
concept I think.
DAN SCOTT: Yeah, so you have
a spectrum of datastores
all the way from sort of
like a Redis key-value store
all the way to your
traditional MySQL.
And Firebase, the
real time database
is a little bit more powerful
than a key-value store,
but certainly is not
a relational database.
And it has all of
these fantastic
notion of shared
state, which lets
you do things like create Google
Docs without a team of Google
engineers, or lets you power
the notifications widget
on Facebook without writing a
distributed real time system.
MARTIN OMANDER: Right.
When I talk to people out there
in the developer community
of what Firebase is,
I often have to say,
forget what you know
about databases.
Now we're going to
talk about Firebase.
It's a slightly
different animal.
And it does all
these cool things
that you didn't know
a database could do.
Cool.
All right, thank you guys.
We have one more video question.
And this one is from
Sheldon McGee in Arizona.
Could we roll Sheldon's
question please?
SHELDON MCGEE: I was
looking at the pricing page.
And before it said,
full cloud integration
was one of the standard features
for the highest priced tier.
It looks like it was recently
renamed to the Google Cloud
Platform, and they take out
that language altogether.
But what does that
mean actually?
What does it mean to be
integrated with the platform
that it all runs on?
Do you think that
would be something
that was standard across
all different price points?
MARTIN OMANDER: Oh,
so a pricing question.
Interesting.
James, do you want
to take this one?
JAMES TAMPLIN: Yeah, so
as I mentioned earlier,
we're working hard to
really deeply integrate
Firebase in Google Cloud.
For those of you who have
used Google Cloud previously,
you'll know that there is no
sort of perpetual free tier,
whereas Firebase there is.
And so the reason that full
Google Cloud integration
isn't available on anything
except our Blaze Plan is so
that we can align those models.
We really think the Google Cloud
integration is super powerful.
As I mentioned, you have
a full cloud platform.
If you've followed any
of the Google Cloud stuff
that's been going on in
the last field few months,
you'll have heard about all
the amazing stuff they're
doing, especially around
things like machine learning
and vision.
And so getting access to those
and pairing with your Firebase
app is really, really powerful.
MARTIN OMANDER: Right.
You get the best of both
worlds there, right?
JAMES TAMPLIN: Exactly.
And we want to support
you across your lifecycle.
So whether you're getting
started on Firebase
and needing to grow into
all the toolset on Cloud,
or if you're using
Cloud and want
to add a mobile
application, we want
to make those
transitions really easy.
MARTIN OMANDER: Right.
Good stuff, good stuff.
Thank you James.
So now we are on to our
Twitter and Google+ questions.
And the first one
we have is actually,
speaking about
machine learning, does
Firebase have any functionality
useful for developers looking
to implement machine learning?
Who's taking--
JAMES TAMPLIN: So I think that
dovetails really nicely out
of the last question.
So there's a couple of things.
One is Cloud ML, Cloud Machine
Learning, our of Google Cloud.
And then obviously
Google released
TensorFlow as an open source
project, which is pretty great.
Nothing sort of directly
integrated into the core suite,
but you can pick up some
great offerings from Google
and use them.
I'm not sure exactly
what you're doing Matt,
but check those out.
MARTIN OMANDER: Machine learning
is a big area, isn't it?
Ian?
IAN BARBER: You can put your
TensorFlow models in storage.
You can do that.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: For sure.
MARTIN OMANDER:
[INAUDIBLE] in real time.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: But
it's also the case
that there's a lot of power
that comes from the cloud.
And with Firebase being a very
simple way of developing apps,
it's kind of helping
to integrate these two
worlds together.
With Firebase now launched, I
see the app development process
is so much simpler.
And that also allows you to more
effectively use the services
that the cloud can
offer from your device
when you're a developer.
JAMES TAMPLIN: I need to
prognosticate slightly,
we don't think of certain tasks,
for example like synchronizing
data across clients,
as difficult anymore,
because you have services like
Firebase real time database. .
And looking forward
into the future,
I think it will be commonplace
that-- take a vision example.
I point my camera at an object,
and I can take a picture
and the app knows what that is.
And so I think some
of these services
will get built into a large
number of our applications
that we as consumers
use, and they'll
be powered by services like
Cloud ML and Cloud Vision
and things like that.
MARTIN OMANDER: Right.
Yeah, and even in
my hobby project,
I've seen that pairing
with the rest of the cloud
is very powerful.
I use, for example,
App Engine to just do
deep linking and rewriting
of URLs as such that
that is hard to do in Angular,
and then together with Angular
and Firebase and App Engine.
And they all just works
beautifully together.
All right, thank you.
We have another question
from social media.
If I use-- this is
Matt Thompson who's
asking-- if I use analytics
or have users create
an account with
some personal info,
do I need a privacy
policy on my app?
JAMES TAMPLIN: I think
the simple answer
there is if you're collecting
personal information
about a user, you should
have a privacy policy that
states what you're collecting.
IAN BARBER: Yeah, absolutely.
And you always want to
consult with a local counsel
on those kind of things.
The laws on what you need
to say in those policies
are going to vary
depending on the region.
So it's always best to find
out from an expert what
you should be saying.
MARTIN OMANDER: That's right.
Yeah, it seems like
a privacy policy
seems like the right thing
to do with regards to laws
too, right?
All right, so the
next question is
from Mohammad Kamran who
is asking, Node.js SDK,
the Node.js SDK now supports
only create token and verify.
So how do we do other
stuff like access
and update database,
or create user?
IAN BARBER: So I think what
happened here is actually
we kind of split
things up a little bit
when we're pushing
the new release out.
So the Node.js SDK supports
all of the database.
We have a separate
chunk of the SDK
which is focused on
creating custom tokens
and verifying Firebase tokens.
So that's like new as
those features have
been developed in this release.
But the database
SDK is right there.
So you can, once you've
got an authenticated user,
you can go off and you
can query the database.
You can update it, do all
that same kind of stuff
you do before.
MARTIN OMANDER: I see.
Got it.
All right, the next one we
have is from Michael Prentice
in Florida.
Michael is asking, is there an
up to date guide or blog post
for migrating a MEAN
or Node.js/MongoDB app
to Firebase?
Are there are tools for this?
People often ask me
this question as well.
What's the official answer?
IAN BARBER: So well I mean,
Angular works super well.
Angular's been one
of the big things
with Firebase for
a very long time,
and it's still something--
we've got people on the team
very involved with the Angular
core team and vice versa.
So Angular and Firebase
are a really good fit.
And then the migration
is really you're
dropping aspects of that.
You don't need the MongoDB
and you don't need expressive
if you've got these apps.
You've got Firebase hosting
and you've got Angular.
So I think the migrations should
be fairly straightforward.
JAMES TAMPLIN: Delete some code?
IAN BARBER: Yeah, hopefully.
MARTIN OMANDER: Best kind of
refactoring there is, right?
Angular and Firebase
just seem like they're
made for each other, right?
Write one or two lines
of code and update
what is shown in
the browser, what
is in the JavaScript model,
and what is in the database.
That's pretty much it.
IAN BARBER: The
whole thing is we've
got the same kind of concept
listening or binding.
It's really the
same set of ideas.
And it just lets you flow all
the way back to the cloud.
JAMES TAMPLIN: We actually
coined the phrase.
So Angular had two way
binding between the DOM
and your JavaScript models.
And so we went to ng-conf I
guess 2 and 1/2 years ago now,
introduced three
way binding which
bound it to a model in the
cloud, which was the real time
database.
So when you updated
the DOM, it obviously
synced across all clients.
And so Firebase and Angular
have been working together
for a long time.
And we're hard at work
building and improving
integrations for Angular 2
and the new Firebase 3.x SDKs.
MARTIN OMANDER:
Actually on that James,
so with the new SDK,
the new Firebase SDK,
that works with Angular 1.x.
Or how is it with Angular 2?
IAN BARBER: There's
a matrix of options.
You've got Angular.
So you have Angular
1 and 2, which
are both ongoing projects.
Angular 2 is recently launched,
ng-conf, and is going well.
We have AngularFire
1 and AngularFire 2
to support those two.
Both of those at the moment
go against the 2.x SDK.
So that's where they come--
MARTIN OMANDER: The 2.x--
IAN BARBER: Firebase.
So those currently work.
And if you have an app
using them, you're good.
Nothing's going to
happen to that app.
You can keep using it.
We're working at the
moment to update them
to the 3 SDK for Firebase.
So that's the new
features we launched.
And you can follow along.
These are open source projects.
You can see the pull
requests coming in.
And feel free to
send some as well.
MARTIN OMANDER: Oh cool.
This is the AngularFire--
IAN BARBER: AngularFire, yeah.
MARTIN OMANDER: Great,
an amazing library.
I use it all the time.
All right, good stuff.
Another question from
Michael Prentice in Florida
is how can I define
the REST API URI
format of just taking the
Firebase database default URIs?
JAMES TAMPLIN: So the
quick answer is you-- well
I think what you want to do is
CNAME them to your own domain.
If that is the
question you're asking,
then unfortunately
you can't do that.
So it's firebaseio.com is
the base of the URI path.
IAN BARBER: But you can bring
your own domain to the hosting.
So if you're
deploying a web app,
you don't have to have that
app on name.firebaseapp.com.
You can bring your own domain
and have your web app living
on there.
And then under the
hood it's going
to connect to these REST URLs.
But yeah, those URLs,
you can't change those.
MARTIN OMANDER: So I think
that's a very important
distinction brought
up there Ian.
So the URL that the
user sees in the browser
is whatever they want
it to be, their domain.
And then under the hood the
traffic goes to a Firebase URL.
IAN BARBER: Exactly yeah.
MARTIN OMANDER: Got it, OK.
Very good.
The next question we have
is from Trish Whetzel
in Silicon Valley.
And she's saying legacy
Firebase lists third party REST
wrappers at a URL.
Will Firebase bring these
in-house and maintain?
JAMES TAMPLIN: So quick point
of contention I have with this,
there is no legacy Firebase.
There's just one Firebase.
And we have obviously
upgraded a bunch of pieces
and give it a new website.
The third party REST
wrapper, those were always
written by the community.
And we've been engaged
there and really tried
to help and facilitate,
make those really great,
but sort of never taken them
on as official libraries.
I don't for sure if we
will or not in the future.
But interesting suggestion,
something we can look in.
IAN BARBER: Yeah, I
think one of things
is-- we've had this discussion
quite a lot at Google
in general on the
open source projects
that are using services
that maybe we work on.
Sometimes it makes
sense for those
to be maintained in-house.
My preferred situation is
actually when we can contribute
and we can go and work
on an open source project
and actually contribute
our changes just
to whatever you guys are doing,
because there's a lot more
of you than there are of us.
And in some cases it
really wouldn't make sense
to bring them
in-house, because we
have a certain set of expertise
and a certain set of languages
we work in.
And the community
is like an explosion
of different languages,
different systems.
And someone that's bringing
a lot of idiomatic knowledge
in that language is going
to be able to do a better
job of building a
client around an API
than we are much of the time.
And so our kind of
focus has often been,
let's get the APIs standardized
and clear and reliable
so that we can put that out
that and we can document that.
And then if the community
wants to build on top of it,
then we can support
them wherever we can.
MARTIN OMANDER: I
really like that,
especially as someone who's
written client code for Google
APIs, I can say that I did an
OK job of writing a .NET library
for a Google API.
But once the community
took it over,
they made it sort
of .NET idiomatic.
And it sort of worked for .NET
developers far better than
my initial version.
Who is writing the
AngularFire library?
IAN BARBER: There's
still a few people.
Gosh, Jeff Cross, David East.
I'm forgetting people.
Apologies to all those people.
JAMES TAMPLIN: I
think it's like 50.
IAN BARBER: There's
a big community.
Look at the contributors.
It's
github.com/angular/angularfire2.
Click on the contributors.
There's a ton of people
that have worked on that.
And thank you to all of them.
MARTIN OMANDER: Thank you
as someone who uses it.
I mean for me, it's just magic.
I include AngularFire, and wow.
I didn't even realize there
were that many people.
But I guess that
is needed if you're
going to get this three
way magic binding?
IAN BARBER: Well the
actual core of these things
is not actually that hard.
It's the edge cases and
all the details that
go into a library that like.
The 80% cases are usually
pretty straightforward,
especially when you're
dealing with something
like-- the Firebase
database is not--
if you ever look
at the REST API,
it's not super complicated.
If you look at the SDKs,
they're not super complicated.
Like the majority
of cases are, I'm
going to listen for
values coming in.
I'm going to push something
in or I'm going to update.
These are where you're going
to spend most of your time.
But once you start getting into
the querying or the filtering,
you start having
to do more work.
So to get something
working is actually--
if you're looking
at a language that
doesn't have a binding to it,
to get something working that
likely solves your problem is
not a big investment of time.
If you want to wrap
every single feature,
it starts becoming
more effort, which
is why the team on AngularFire
2 and the other bindings
can grow as they're
catching these edge cases
and building out all these
features that the database
sorts.
MARTIN OMANDER: Right, right.
Yeah, the edge cases,
they'll get you every time.
All right, good stuff.
We have another question
from Sheldon McGee-- wow,
lots of questions.
Thanks Sheldon.
Another question from
Sheldon in Arizona,
which is, are Firebase
Analytics and Firebase
Messaging all new products,
or are they renamed
and updated versions
of previous projects?
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: So it's a mix.
Firebase Analytics is built
completely from scratch just
to be a great mobile analytics
solution for developers.
But then there are
other APIs that
have existed for some time
in Google Play services
for example.
App Invites for
example, is one of them.
App Indexing probably
people have heard of.
So those APIs, as they
make a lot of sense
for every developer developing
an app to engage users,
they are an inherent,
important piece of Firebase.
So that's why they've been
brought in as features
of this entire product.
MARTIN OMANDER: And we were
talking about for these,
you described Magnus, it's
not simply a rebranding.
They're actually integrated.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: Exactly.
They're tightly integrated.
All of these APIs--
I think all is
accurate-- they integrate
with Analytics so you
can get analytics data from it.
So that's really what
Firebase is all about.
Rather than having to
deal with individual API,
look at this from a
holistic perspective,
a coherent set of features
that make sense and are
well integrated when you
develop apps so the work
as a developer is as
painless as Possible
MARTIN OMANDER: And when we're
talking about developer pain,
some of these fit nicely into
Android Studio too, right?
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: Sure.
I mean, there are plug-ins
now in Android Studio
to help with
Firebase development.
And this just the initial
relieves after the initial
features that existed
as part of Firebase.
So right now it's grown up to
14 or 15 I think we have there.
And now we really have
time to focus and improve
and incrementally get
this product a lot better.
So those integrations,
all of them,
they will become
better as time goes by.
JAMES TAMPLIN: I think Firebase
Messaging or Firebase Cloud
Messaging that was
in the question
is a specific one to highlight.
So this is Google Cloud
Messaging that many of you
know and love and sends
billion of messages a day,
and was rebranded
and integrated,
as Magnus mentioned,
because Firebase
is this integrated suite of
tools for mobile developers.
But second, to really highlight
its cross platform nature.
It's not just a push
messaging tool for Android.
You can send to iOS
as well and we're
working with browser vendors
to make sure it can send it
down to the web as well.
MARTIN OMANDER: Down
to the web as well?
That's really useful, yeah.
Good stuff.
And I guess it makes
sense with Analytics
being completely
a brand new thing,
because app analytics on
your phone is quite a bit
different than web analytics.
IAN BARBER: It's that
the needs are different.
I think this is the
thing with analytics
is you're coming from a world
where we have a lot of people
who are very good at
working with Google
Analytics and products with
it, for understanding how
web content is consumed and used
and optimized based on that.
And GA is an amazing
tool for doing that.
Firebase Analytics just
changed that initial model,
that initial model of going from
pages to just going to events,
and thinking of it more
as a flow where we have
all of those events captured.
And you can actually
really start drilling
into the details of them.
I think that that
distinction is relatively
small at the actual
implementation level, SDK
implementation level.
If you go and swap out
an existing items package
or add in Firebase
Analytics, it's
not going to be that much code.
This is pretty straightforward.
But the implementation of the
backend and the processing
and the reporting that goes on
in that is pretty substantial.
So it was a big effort
to launch that product.
MARTIN OMANDER: All right, yeah.
And I've seen some
of these companies.
If you have a company
that has an app that
has a substantial
number of installs,
you have a lot of
data, because you're
tracking every click basically.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: And that was
one thing that was important
with Firebase Analytics was
free and unlimited, to be
able to provide mobile
developers with that.
So if you haven't looked
at Firebase Analytics,
I strongly urge the developers
out there to take a look.
IAN BARBER: It's like you
can get started with no code.
You can started just
adding the dependency.
If you add the Firebase core
dependency on Android or iOS,
it will just start tracking
some basic metrics, app installs
and sessions and
things like that.
So you don't have to go and
change you app to give it a try
and start seeing whether
the data in the dashboard
is useful.
MARTIN OMANDER: Oh, I like
that, no code integration.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: You're
getting us started here.
But there's so
many capabilities.
Just the fact that you can
use analytics data to build
audiences, segment groups,
and all of these things ties
into other products.
James talked about Config.
Using Analytics data,
you can build audiences.
And that can then feed into
Config, and you can use Config.
Using audiences, you
can send notifications
to just those people that
are matching that criteria.
So there's a lot of
integration there
that would be
extremely difficult
and a lot of work to do if
you had to do it from scratch.
All of that you get for
free when you use Firebase,
because all of that stuff
is integrated right there.
IAN BARBER: And there's some
cool edge case integrations
and things on that.
If you want to say, you want
to keep Google Analytics
for-- if you're using
Google Analytics on the web
and you want to have
Firebase Analytics.
You can use Tag Manager to
repeat events over to GA.
So you can set it
up so that you have
Firebase Analytics in your app.
And that's automatically
feeding into Tag Manager.
Tag Manager is going
to go out and fire
those events [INAUDIBLE].
JAMES TAMPLIN: But Ian,
what's Tag Manager?
[LAUGHTER]
IAN BARBER: Smooth.
If anyone hasn't
encountered Tag Manager,
Tag Manager is a technology that
sort of came from the web world
where you often ended
up wanting to have
multiple different analytics
trackers or combustion trackers
for different services.
And it lets you effectively
just route events.
So you're coming and
saying, someone's
come through and
converted on this.
You can go and send that
to the appropriate trackers
on the server side.
So you get a really
flexible system
that you can control even
once your app is out there
and has been deployed.
MARTIN OMANDER: And I
think about Tag Manager.
Whenever I hear that, I think
about Dan Baran in Chicago,
who I think is watching us now.
Hi Dan.
When Dan and I show up at
events, he always gives a talk.
He's not a Googler, but he
gives a talk on Tag Manager.
And then I ask, Dan,
what is Tag Manager?
And he said, you know,
every Googler asks me that.
But it's the greatest
hidden Google feature
that people don't know about.
And they should all use it.
So Tag Manager, use it.
All right, so our next
question is about,
is feeding Firebase
Analytics data
to BigQuery only possible on
the highest pricing tier, Blaze?
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN:
That's true, yes.
And this is one of the--
Blaze has the full cloud
integration as part of it.
And BigQuery is one of
those products in Cloud
that actually costs money.
So it makes a lot of sense to
have it together with Blaze.
MARTIN OMANDER: And
BigQuery, for those
who haven't heard
about what BigQuery is,
it's a pretty amazing product.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: That's one of
the coolest Google products.
IAN BARBER: Can you
do BigQuery though?
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: No, BigQuery
is a database product
which allows you to
do SQL like statements
on petabytes of data.
So you can take huge
data sets and analyze
them using BigQuery in a very
rapid and performant way.
So it's really
for data analytics
and looking at big data
and all of these things,
it is a very unique solution.
And Analytics,
Firebase Analytics,
in order to provide more
flexibility on analyzing
your data, Firebase
Analytics has this capability
to also provide that
data down to BigQuery
so you can write these
big custom queries.
And that's also a feed that
can come from Google Analytics.
So you can actually bring
in Google Analytics data
to BigQuery as well as
Firebase Analytics data.
And then you can
cross correlate them--
IAN BARBER: And a lot
of our data sources.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: And a lot of
other data sources, exactly,
because BigQuery can
get data feeds from,
I guess, most of the
cloud products like,
Cloud Storage and other
data sources as well.
IAN BARBER: And a
lot of third parties
you can integrate
with pretty easily.
And you just start putting
data sources in, pulling them
together, doing queries.
And then you can
plug that into what
you're kind of BI tools is.
If you're using Tableau
or something like that,
that can talk to BigQuery
and you can do all that.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN:
That is amazing.
I mean, I remember just
10 years ago in projects
that I was using, 100 million
rows in a database table, that
was very prohibitive
and we were very scared
of implementing a
solution like that.
With these next generation
tools and distribution
and the scale of Google,
100 million rows suddenly
isn't much data at all.
I mean, we're talking
terabytes and even up
to petabytes in terms of data
sets that can be analyzed.
This was not possible
10 years ago.
MARTIN OMANDER: It
is pretty amazing.
And let's see, what is it,
mega, giga, tera, peta.
OK, it's big.
It's big.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: Exa.
MARTIN OMANDER:
Exa comes after it.
Yes, very good.
Good stuff.
All right, so our next question
is from Roberto Martin.
He's asking, my apps uses
GCM, Google Cloud Messaging.
I would like to
update to Firebase
to use the other services.
Is Firebase Cloud
Message production ready.
IAN BARBER: I've got this one.
Yes.
[APPLAUSE]
It is a great service.
FCM is built by the
team that did GCM.
This is a new version
that they've put together.
This is bringing out really
just a lot of improvements.
But the base layer is still
that code that already worked.
MARTIN OMANDER: Oh, so if the
previous one worked for you,
the new one will.
JAMES TAMPLIN: Yeah, it send
170 billion messages a day.
It's very production ready.
MARTIN OMANDER: You
forced all of my question.
I was going to ask,
is anybody using it?
But 170 billion messages,
I guess somebody is.
IAN BARBER: One or two.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: And as part
of the launch of FCM also,
we've heard a lot of good
feedback on simplification,
the API improvements as well.
IAN BARBER: Yeah, absolutely.
The API got a lot easier to use.
There's a lot less,
particular if get
started-- I think in this case
if you're coming from a GCM
integration, if you
were using the GCM v3,
then coming out to this
is a very easy move.
But if you're starting from
scratch, it's even easier.
Like if you're starting from
scratch, it's really just,
you can get this stuff going.
I think actually again, if
you're sending notifications
from the Firebase
Notifications Console,
you can get some of that
working with, again, no code.
It's just the dependency
is going to go in there,
and that's going to take care
of a lot of that for you.
So that's cool.
And it's not that
we expect everyone
who is deploying this stuff
to do so with no code.
Of course you're
going to want to have
notification handling of your
own and do things with it.
But we want you to spend
time writing that code,
not to writing kind of
boilerplate and things
for just receiving those
messages in the first place.
MARTIN OMANDER: Right.
I think that bears repeating
and emphasizing, right?
The Messaging Console, you
can go in there on a web page.
And a nontechnical person
could put a message in there
and send it out to a
subset of your users,
and can pick which segment even.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: So it says
notification on the left hand
side of the console.
That's Firebase
Notifications where
you can do all of these things.
And again, it integrates
with Firebase Analytics,
so you can build audiences
based on your analytics data,
and then use that audience
to target your messages.
IAN BARBER: And you can schedule
and all that kind of stuff.
There was one of the partners
at-- we had a kind of Firebase
in the real world session
at I/O, which is on YouTube.
One of the partners
there was talking
about how they wanted to
do a bunch of campaign type
messages.
And they didn't want to stay up.
And so they can
just schedule them.
MARTIN OMANDER: Oh,
stay up in the--
IAN BARBER: Yeah,
because they want
them to come at a sensible
time for each time zone,
not at the time they
happen to be up.
So if they're in Korea and
their audience was in the US,
then they want to have that go
at a sensible time in the US.
So little things
like that, you just
don't have to do that
yourself anymore.
You can take advantage of this.
MARTIN OMANDER: Right.
Because I've talked
to app developers,
successful app developers,
who wanted to do all this.
But they had to
build it themselves.
And like you were
saying, you end up
having to build
a lot of plumbing
when you're not
a plumber, right?
You're a game developer
or enterprise developer.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN:
And that's really,
I mean-- that's really
a huge value, building
this next level-- in the
stack or app development,
this is all of these
things ready to use.
I often say, with Firebase I
could sit down after lunch,
and by 5 o'clock,
I would understand
a lot of the
components, see a lot
of the component in Firebase
that I would use in order
to build an effective app.
If I didn't have
Firebase, I would
have to go out and search
and look for solutions.
And they wouldn't be
integrated at all,
would take a lot more
time and be a lot more
complex than using Firebase.
MARTIN OMANDER: Wasn't it
one of the computing greats
like Dijkstra or
somebody like that
who said that the only advance
we've ever had in computing
is successive abstraction.
Everything else is details.
Sounds like this
is bringing that.
All right, I think our
last question before we go
to a break/ So this is from
Brandon M. Hunter who's asking,
can you share production
apps that uses Firebase?
Do we have some
things we can mention?
IAN BARBER: There's
a whole bunch
on firebase.google.com/customers
that are there.
If you're watching
some of the I/O talks,
you might have seen
apps like IS, Shazam.
Who else did we have in--
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: NPR.
IAN BARBER: NPR, yeah.
JAMES TAMPLIN: SeatGeek is
using us, Viber, TuneIn.
There's a whole bunch.
And then these are the partners.
We're listing
partners and customers
that we've been working with
in the last six months who've
been giving us feedback on
all of the great features.
But there's
thousands-- as you saw,
470,000 developers who were
using prior to last Wednesday.
Citrix uses us to power
parts of GoToMeeting.
CBS uses us to power parts of
the social experience for some
of their television shows.
Instacart uses us
for a whole variety
of things, social, shopping.
So yeah, lots and lots and
lots of people are using it.
MARTIN OMANDER: And I
think that's a good point.
So you said, James, that we
have hundreds of thousands
of, as we saw in the graph,
using the database component.
We know that.
JAMES TAMPLIN: And
authentication and hosting.
MARTIN OMANDER: And
And some of these partners
you mentioned here
are ones who have been in
the sort of prepublic beta
using these new features
we're talking about today,
messaging and so on.
So they are not brand new,
raw, and experimental.
People are using those features.
JAMES TAMPLIN: Exactly.
So we've been working
on this for-- Firebase
has been at Google.
The acquired company has
been at Google for 18 months
and have been working hard.
And there's been an extensive
what we call early access
program where we go out to
trusted partners and trusted
customers and say hey,
what do you think of this?
And it's always
been core to sort
of the Firebase philosophy
of test and iterate
and check out this
version of the API.
What do you think?
How could we improve?
And rapidly iterating and
getting product managers
and engineers, in addition to
our developer relations folks,
really engaging and interacting
and understanding the pain
points of our customers.
And ultimately that's
going to ensure
that we're delivering the best
platform and the best products.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: And
the feedback so far
has been fantastic
since we launched
at Google I/O. It was
really so nice to get
the initial feedback.
And it was really
great feedback.
And it was very well
received I think.
IAN BARBER: And
there's definitely
some credit to those partner
companies we worked with.
So if any of them are
watching, thank you.
It was really good to be
able to put this stuff out
there and get feedback and
have people try it, and then
actually get the confidence
to launch it in production
and be saying yes, this
stuff is working for us.
It's making a difference.
MARTIN OMANDER: And I guess
if some of these integrations
are no code integrations,
some people have integrated
since last Wednesday already.
IAN BARBER: Probably.
MARTIN OMANDER: All
right, good stuff.
So it is 4 o'clock here
in the Pacific time zone.
So this means it's time
for us all to take a break.
We may need some bio break.
Also, this is your chance
to take a bio break.
This is your chance to keep
posting photos of your viewing
party at #AskFirebaseLive,
or to post
more questions for our panel.
And we will be back
in five minutes.
See you in five.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARTIN OMANDER:
Hey, welcome back.
We are back here.
It took a little more
than five minutes,
but I've been drinking
a lot of tea today.
So we're here.
Everybody's back,
feeling rested.
Moved around a bit, yeah?
Good stuff.
Ready for some more
questions guys?
Yeah, good stuff.
So here is a question that
I get every single time
I speak about Firebase.
So I'm really glad
it came up and I
didn't have to put my
name on this question.
And I actually don't
know the answer.
And Matt Wilson doesn't either.
So please let me and Matt know.
How are synchronization
conflicts
dealt with in the Realtime
Database, and particularly
when devices go offline?
This is tricky, right?
If you try to write
code yourself for this,
this is tricky.
How does Firebase do it?
JAMES TAMPLIN:
Yeah, it is tricky.
So Firebase Realtime
Database has
two main ways of dealing with
synchronization conflicts.
And there's two ways to write
into the Firebase database.
One is the last write wins.
And so this is the set
method or the update method.
And you can call update
on a complex object
and it will just update
the individual values
that have changed.
And so if you have
multiple clients,
whoever gets to the server
last, that's the truth.
The second way of doing
conflict resolution
is through a transaction.
And so it's a version of
optimistic concurrency.
And so what you
have on the client
is you have a mutator function.
And so what it
does is it you pass
into that mutator function
the current state of the data
and want you want
to transform into.
And then what it does is
it does the transformation,
and it sends it up to the
server with a hash of the data
that it thinks the server has.
And if the hash is matched,
it commits and tells
the client like hey, you won.
This is the true value.
Congratulations.
If the hash doesn't match, it
will take the server value.
It'll send it back
to the client.
And it'll rerun the mutator
function with that new state
that it's got from the server.
And it will keep
trying and keep trying.
So if you have, say, you're
incrementing a counter
from one to 10 and there are
two people trying to do it,
and it says hey,
add one to three.
It should be four.
And the server says no, actually
the old value isn't three,
the new value is four.
It'll send it back down,
increment, and then keep going.
So that's kind of
how the two versions
of writing to the
Firebase database.
And the mutator
function gives you
kind of a lot of
flexibility, because you
can put your own custom logic
in there to handle whatever
edge cases you may need to.
MARTIN OMANDER: Oh, so I can
actually have a counter then,
like number of people logged
in or something like that,
and it deals with it so
that two people won't try
to update it at the same time?
JAMES TAMPLIN: Yep, exactly.
MARTIN OMANDER: And then so
let's say I'm writing code.
I'm a developer.
I'm writing code for this.
I want to do increase the
number of logged in users.
I want to increment it by one.
And if two people were doing
it at the same time, what
does it look like for
me as a programmer?
Is there like an
exceptional on my client?
How do I handle it on
my client side code?
JAMES TAMPLIN: So you
don't have to do anything.
It will keep trying
until it succeeds.
So it'll just automatically run
the function until it commits.
MARTIN OMANDER: Oh, very nice.
Very nice.
All right, I didn't know that.
Now I know what to answer when
people ask me the question.
Thank you.
All right, another question
we had from techwithchance.
Nice tag, nice handle.
Would you give us a
couple of examples of how
one could use Remote Config?
Yeah, Remote Config
sounds a little abstract.
Could you give us some
more concrete example?
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: One
example is simply
to store, rather than
having constants in your app
and coding them into class
or resource files for Android
or iOS, you can
have those retrieved
from the app towards
Remote Config
so you get those
values from the cloud.
So if you have data that
you may want to change
or if you want to try different
values of those things--
for example, user interface,
colors, et cetera,
et cetera-- all of those things
can be configured in the cloud.
And you can change
them in the cloud,
and they will have effect
in the app as well.
This allows you to try
different areas to tie-in
with Analytics audiences again.
This allows you to try different
values for different people.
So you can see how
the app is being used
by different sets of people.
So you can try new things
out in a dynamic fashion--
this is called A/B testing--
to see the optimum layout
or solution for
your app in terms
of these configurable values.
MARTIN OMANDER: Oh, so I can
say that today my app has
a red background,
and then I change
and tomorrow it will be blue.
And I don't have to
recompile and send it out.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: No, no need
to recompile or redistribute
in any way.
MARTIN OMANDER: You're smiling.
IAN BARBER: It's one
of those-- the thing
to think about with Remote
Conflict is stuff like that,
you don't really do.
You don't really
end up going, I'm
going to change the
background color of my app.
You do effectively
control features
or you override
specific information.
So there's roughly
the two cases.
And I'll give you an example.
You might have a set
of strings in your app
that are used to
display certain things.
You might have like
a welcome message.
And you might want
to A/B test, does
changing the welcome
message make sense?
So you would have
a welcome message
as a default in your
app, and then you
can run, exactly as
Magnus was saying,
an A/B test where
you say, give some
of the user's that
welcome message,
give other uses this
welcome message.
So that allows you to
just override a parameter
that you've got in your app.
The other kind of
use is really about--
MARTIN OMANDER: Sorry
for interrupting you,
and I just want to make
sure I understand here.
So I could say, have half my
audiences see happy holidays
and half of them
see merry Christmas.
And then I could actually
get analytics broken down
by those audiences and
see which one works best?
IAN BARBER: So you
would use Analytics.
You would use a
property to do that.
So the way we kind of suggest
is you'd say, yeah, holiday
greeting, a user property.
And then base on what the
value was from Config,
you would set the value
of that user property.
So you might say cohort
A, cohort B, and so on.
Then you could go
into Analytics.
You could filter against
that user property.
And you could see,
oh yeah, I've got
a higher uplift in
retention for users
that got this than got that.
And you can have
multiple variables.
You don't have to have
just one A/B group.
You can have as many
groups as you need.
And you don't have to
just have one thing.
If you're testing a
collection of changes,
you can go and put those out.
I think that usage
also flips into kind
of the main thing people
are using Remote Config for,
which is control of features.
So you are in a situation where
maybe you've added something
to your app, like
maybe you've got a game
and you've added a real time
multiplayer feature that
is very intensive
on your backend--
you're doing a lot of
processing or something
like that-- that is
not an easy feature.
You think you're
good, but you don't
want to just turn this
on and then suddenly see
all your stuff fall over.
So you could
control that feature
with a variable, which
defaults to false.
And it's configured
in Remote Config.
Then you could ramp it.
So you say OK, 2% of users
have this, 5%, 50%, whatever.
And you can also turn it off.
So if like, oh
your game suddenly
gets featured in something and
is getting absolutely hammered,
and that is just causing
a very bad experience,
you can just disable that.
And maybe you can even then send
a notification to those people
from the Notification
Console saying hey,
the multiplayer
will come back soon.
So at least they
understand what's going on.
So those are really
the two areas
that people use
remote config for.
MARTIN OMANDER: So
this sounds like stuff
that people have been
doing on the web.
And I've heard
developers say this,
they've been doing
this sort of thing
on the web for some years,
but what they've found it,
until now I guess, very hard to
do it in the mobile app world.
But now they can and test
which picture converts
the best, which message.
Should I try-- it's
free shipping, $50,
if the order's $50 or more.
No, I changed my
mind, $40 instead.
Pretty cool stuff.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: And you can
have default values as well.
So in case you have
a network disruption,
you can't connect to the
cloud, Remote Config API,
the client side API can
return default values.
So you can ensure that the
app is working at all times.
IAN BARBER: Yeah,
and realistically,
if you're looking
at implementing,
implement it with defaults.
So it can be tempting to
think of Remote Config
as like oh, I'll go in and
put every single variable
into the console.
But what you probably want is
to actually launch your app
with nothing in the console.
You have everything at launch
time is in the defaults.
And only when you want to
override one of those variables
for all or some subset
of your audience
do you actually go and set up
an entry in the console for it.
So it's slightly different
than you might expect.
If you do have a situation
where you're like oh,
but I actually want all this
data only to live in the cloud,
you probably want
to use the database,
because the information's there.
It's going to be
synced to real time.
That's probably
the right choice.
If you're looking
to do overrides,
Remote Conflict gives you
that flexibility there.
MARTIN OMANDER:
Are there concerns,
or should I think about
performance with Remote Config?
It's OK to put it in some places
in my app but not in others,
say, or?
IAN BARBER: I mean,
Remote Config's
actually pretty much always
going to run locally.
So there's a local
cache on the device
is where the values
will be run from.
It's going to go
into an asynchronous
fetch for that data.
So you're never going to be
stuck waiting for this thing
to happen, other than from
that very initial file read
of local device.
MARTIN OMANDER: Oh really, OK.
JAMES TAMPLIN: And
it uses Firebase
cloud messaging to actually
do the transport, which
has been optimized for battery
efficiency and reliability.
MARTIN OMANDER: Oh nice, nice.
IAN BARBER: That's a good point.
MARTIN OMANDER: Good stuff.
All right, next we
have Allen Firstenberg
from New York who is asking,
can Firebase notifications
be sent via an API or
just via the console?
We talked about the console
before and how easy it was.
And also is there an API
for most console operations?
IAN BARBER: I'm sure Allen
asked me this question in person
as well.
[LAUGHTER]
MARTIN OMANDER: Has
the answer changed?
IAN BARBER: No it doesn't.
So Firebase
notifications is really
what we're thinking is for
the UI and the console,
so the ability to go in and
schedule messages and send
them.
The Firebase Cloud
Messaging has an API.
So you can do those things.
You can go in and send messages.
You can send to topics.
You can do that, that same
functionality via an API.
But in our sort of minds, that's
part of the Firebase Cloud
Messaging thing.
In terms of the APIs, it
depends with the product.
Like obviously Database has
a very complete RESTful API.
And you can use that.
Not everything
does at the moment.
And it's something
that we're looking at
based on where people
are going and where
the demand is for each product.
MARTIN OMANDER: So with
the Cloud Messaging,
would most developers
use the console
to enter their messages there?
Would most write an app
or local code for it?
What do you think?
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: It all depends
on-- I mean, if you actually
have a message and know that
a human will decide and write
this message, then the
console makes a lot of sense
because you can go in
as a human and do that.
Let's say you have data
in a backend database
and that backend data drives
whether a message should
be sent or not.
That's more an
automated process.
And in that case, it
makes a lot of sense
to program that
using FCM instead.
MARTIN OMANDER: Oh right, like
your account is about to expire
or something like that.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN:
Correct, exactly.
MARTIN OMANDER:
Yeah then you need
to send it very surgically
to one person at a time.
IAN BARBER: I think the
FCM team referred to
as like transactional
notifications, which
a thing has happened,
so do this thing,
versus an engagement
notification, which
is like hey, do you want
to know about this thing?
So you might want to send
out manually a message
to tell people oh,
there's a new sticker
pack available in your app.
That's reasonable, and you
want to choose when to do that,
because you're doing
it about the audience.
Everyone in this country gets a
sticker pack at the same time.
I want to send it
at a time they're
awake and using their phones.
But the transactional
notification,
I might want to send it right
away if it's like oh, you've
received a new message.
I can send that right away.
So for those kind of things,
you'll have to use the API.
JAMES TAMPLIN: And really the
split between Firebase Cloud
Messaging and
Firebase Notifications
is, as Ian described,
transactional verses marketing
or campaigns.
We really thought
about in terms of,
who is the persona
within your organization?
Who will be sending these?
And typically a developer
would be wiring up
transactional push
notifications, which
will be done through an API.
And your marketing or
your growth hackers
or whoever you have who
are saying hey, this user's
about to churn.
Haven't seen him in 30 days.
Let's send a notification
to that audience.
And that will really be
done through the console.
MARTIN OMANDER: Oh I
see, different personas.
Yep, that's a good way
of thinking about it.
All right, good stuff.
Our next question is from
Josh Wilson, who is asking,
how long did you guys spend
putting together the Firebase
puzzle?
That was a lot of fun.
I have actually heard
many developers tell me
that this was a lot
of-- not very easy,
but a lot of fun,
this Firebase puzzle.
[LAUGHTER]
Everyone's looking at you guys.
JAMES TAMPLIN: I
will take that one.
It took us a while.
We did have some help
from outside of Google.
We knew it was something
we wanted to do.
But as you can
imagine, it was a bit
of a crunch coming up to I/O.
MARTIN OMANDER: To I/O, yes.
JAMES TAMPLIN: So that was
there as many of us who
sat down and tested it and
gave feedback and guidance
and really helped tweak.
And if you don't
know what this is,
you should go to firebase.foo.
So what we have, for those
of you who don't know,
there's a rogue
fish on the loose.
And it's disrupting one of
the Firebase developer's apps.
And so if you catch the
fish through solving
a series of puzzles, you get a
free ticket to Google I/O 2017.
So that's a pretty big--
those are like gold dust.
So there's a hundred of them.
I think people yesterday
started solving it.
But I still think there's a
lot of I/O 2017 tickets left.
So go to firebase.foo and
see if you can solve it.
MARTIN OMANDER: All right,
good stuff, good stuff.
Yeah, a developer I had
lunch with just the other day
said, that damn puzzle.
One more day I didn't get any
work done one my regular job.
But it was so much fun.
JAMES TAMPLIN: There's
a lot of that threads
on Reddit about it.
It's been really cool
to see the reaction.
MARTIN OMANDER: Cool.
So again James, sorry,
the URL was Firebase--
JAMES TAMPLIN: Firebase.foo.
MARTIN OMANDER: Firebase.foo.
JAMES TAMPLIN: F-O-O.
MARTIN OMANDER:
OK, firebase.foo.
Still tickets and
prizes out there.
Cool.
All right, this is
an interesting one.
All my data-- question
from social media--
all my data must be
stored, hosted in
my country, which is not the US.
We hear a lot about this
from European developers.
Therefore I cannot use Firebase.
Is there any way to
solve this problem?
JAMES TAMPLIN: So the Firebase
Realtime Database and Firebase
Storage currently are--
and Firebase Hosting
as well-- the servers,
ultimately where the data is
located is in the United
States, as the person asking
the question points out.
This is something we
are working quickly on.
So hang tight, and we will
have an answer to this.
MARTIN OMANDER: Oh, cool.
Sounds like we may
have to have you guys
and we'll pick this
question up again.
All right, we have another
social media question.
JWAM, J-W-A-M is asking, what is
a sane strategy when deploying
a new app version requiring new
random Firebase data formats,
but evidently having
multiple app versions active
in the wild?
Right, so I've seen
this with my game also.
It's only a little
hobby project,
but I'm deploying a new
version of the game.
And all of a sudden
I have my score
is in a different place
in the object hierarchy,
or my score is now called
something different.
And now I have multiple
versions of the app.
Some assume the
sort of old schema,
some assume the new schema.
How do you deal with that?
IAN BARBER: So there's a lot of
different techniques depended
on the exact problem.
One of the actual
changes I think
we made in this SDK release
was for the database
for example, if you're doing
the marshaling into objects,
we actually will ignore
extra parameters by default.
So if you add a
parameter, that is safe.
That's a configurable thing.
You can go and change it with
an annotation on the class.
But that will then
be a safe addition.
The real answer is to define
that strategy kind of up front.
You have to choose,
how am I going
to deal with changes
to this data structure?
Because some of the stuff,
if you remove a field which
a version of the
app is depending on,
that's very difficult.
There's very few ways
you can deal with that if
you haven't kind of allowed
for the possibility
ahead of time.
So some of the things you
can do are, try and add
fields instead of anything else.
Try and tag your data
structures with versions
if you think they
are likely to turn.
And then you can
actually check for that
and maybe choose to, oh, this
is a newer data structure.
Just say hey, sorry, please
go and get the new version
of the app if that's something
where you just can't handle it,
your app's too old.
Again, you can take advantage
of these other tools
that we've got in Firebase.
So you can go and send
a notification to users
on the older version, try
and prompt them to upgrade,
maybe offer them some
kind of an incentive.
You can offer them some
in-game currency or something
like that.
Hey, get the latest version.
And you can use Remote
Config to disable features.
So one of the things
I would really
suggest doing with Remote Config
is for big blocks of feature,
see if you can put it in
Remote Config in a way
that you can turn it off.
Because that then gives
you the flexibility of oh,
I'm now three versions later.
I want to do an upgrade here
actually on this old version.
There's just no
way to support it.
I can actually feature flag
that off for that version,
and I know the users
are going-- yeah,
they won't see anything there.
They'll see that
feature isn't available,
and hopefully come
through and upgrade.
But they're not
going to get crashes.
I'm not going to get people
having a really bad experience
with inconsistent data.
Do either of you have any--
JAMES TAMPLIN: No, that's great.
I think schema migration,
it's a problem--
an issue that you have
with many, many databases,
for all databases.
IAN BARBER: All data.
JAMES TAMPLIN: I think
there's a lot of literature
out there on how you do to
schema migrations as well.
MARTIN OMANDER: Right, right.
All right, good stuff.
Our next question is
from Aawaz Gyavali.
Sorry if I didn't get
the pronunciation right.
What is the difference in core
library and analytics library
in Android?
IAN BARBER: Not a lot.
The core library is actually
almost a virtual target.
So it depends on the
analytics library.
Also there's kind of a lot
of dependencies that come in.
Like there's the Firebase
common and Play Services base
just some other utility library
that you don't use directly
in your application code.
So at the moment core and
analytics are the same thing.
We wanted core because
as we move forward,
we want to be able to have
a place that you can know
is reliably going to give
you the core experience
of Firebase, which is at its
heart right now, analytics.
But it is kind of confusing
for people who are looking
for an analytics dependency.
So all of the
actual code for that
lives in the
Analytics [INAUDIBLE].
So it doesn't add any
weight to your app.
You can choose
either one of them.
We recommend core so
that it's kind of you
know you're getting the
base Firebase experience.
And the same's true in iOS.
If you go and look
at that, there's
a subspec Firebase core, which
depends on Firebase analytics.
MARTIN OMANDER: So use core.
IAN BARBER: Use core.
MARTIN OMANDER: Use core.
IAN BARBER: That's
what we'll go with.
MARTIN OMANDER: All right.
Good stuff.
We'll go with that.
The next question is from Thiago
Junior Alves who's asking,
are the defaults for Remote
Config updated from the server
when the app is offline, or does
it revert back to the defaults?
IAN BARBER: So it
updates locally a cache.
So the app ships with defaults.
And then when it fetches
new ones from the server,
those are going to live
there until they expire.
So when you can do a
fetch, you can actually
give it an expiry time.
And once it expires, if there's
no new ones from the server,
it will go back to the defaults.
So it's kind of largely
in your control how
you deal with the
state of where you've
got Config data that's old.
For some things you
might want to go,
really, this should be a long
lived bit of configuration.
For other things you go
hey, if I haven't fetched
and updated value in a while,
just revert to the default.
MARTIN OMANDER: Oh, so you can
set the expiration yourself.
IAN BARBER: You can set
the expiration, yeah.
MARTIN OMANDER: Oh, that's nice.
All right, good stuff.
All right, Dren is asking,
is the new Firebase
console not allow project name--
oh, doesn't the new Firebase
console allow project names
shorter than four characters
and not allow to
customize a prefix domain
name like abcd.firebaseapp.com.
IAN BARBER: I believe
this was directly
implemented to prevent me from
having ian.firebaseapp.com.
JAMES TAMPLIN: I'm sorry Ian.
I apologize.
No, that is one of the
constraints we have.
And yes, the project
you choose assumes
or parlays into the
subdomain that you
have for Firebase hosting.
So that's the
short answer there.
There are some reserve prefixes.
For example, you
can't have something
that begins with Firebase.
There are also some
illegal characters.
I won't name them all now
because I can't remember them.
I think like the dollar sign
and the period or full stop
if you're in a non-US country.
MARTIN OMANDER: I run into most
of those when bugs in my code
try to create-- or
keys with those.
And yeah, it's not happy there.
All right.
Oh, so here's a question
that I actually have.
Well, to be honest,
I didn't realize
I had this question
until I read it on here.
I realize that
like [INAUDIBLE], I
am not separating my
production Analytics
data from my sort of QA builds
and my developer versions
and my various other
sort of in-house builds.
So in my Analytics, all data
from all the test versions,
the production, everything feeds
into that one place, which I
now realize is not very smart.
And so [INAUDIBLE] is asking
how to separate the QA builds,
the Analytics data
coming from QA builds.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN:
Different projects.
IAN BARBER: Yeah, I
mean that's one option.
That's legitimate.
You can create another
project and just associate
that with your QA options.
You can do it in one though.
If you want, the way
to differentiate stuff
in Analytics is with
a user property.
And so you could have
a mode user property
and set it to a value.
But you're limited to
only 25 user properties.
But version is one
of these properties
you get magically for free.
So if you can-- what I've
kind of seen people do is have
version x.x-dev, x.x-QA.
And then you can start
filtering on that.
MARTIN OMANDER: Good stuff.
And as a follow up
to that, when I'm
writing my new version
of the app that
has a slightly different
schema then, and I'm testing it
and so on before
I rolled it out,
do I use the Remote Config to
point to a different Firebase
database?
How do I end up not putting QA
data in my production Firebase
database?
IAN BARBER: Yeah, you could.
Again, that's one of those
questions where a lot of it's
up to your specific needs.
You can have another
database, another project
and use that one for QA.
That works.
You could also
structure your database
so that there is
separate kind of roots
for different environments
so that you write
into a different one of
those and just change out
where you get your root ref.
Instead of having
it as root, you
have root slash prod or root
slash version or however
you want to structure
that kind of stuff.
But yeah, multiple projects
is a fairly reasonable choice.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN:
Because then you
have an absolute
clear separation.
There is no question whatsoever.
Otherwise your QAing your
app and you're sitting there
in Remote Config and you're
configuring key-value things,
and the last thing
you want to do
is effect all your production
users while you really
want to test your Remote Config
for the QA version of your app.
So you always have to juggle
around with all of these things
if you have the same
project for these things.
So really to get a clear demarc
between test environments
and production environments,
using different projects is
the best thing.
JAMES TAMPLIN: And just for
some background knowledge
for those of you who
might be curious,
a project is a container that
can house multiple applications
and has a set of
shared resources.
So here we're talking
about the database.
But we within a project,
you can have, say,
your Android app and your
iOS app and your web app.
And there are specific
characteristics,
say crash reporting, that
you don't want shared.
You just want to know about
specific crashes on my iOS app.
And so that's specific
to the app level
as opposed to the project
level, just as some background.
MARTIN OMANDER:
But you're saying
James, my Android
app and my iOS app
might, for example, write
to the same database.
JAMES TAMPLIN: So every
project has a shared database.
MARTIN OMANDER: Every project
has a shared database.
IAN BARBER: Yeah, you want
those in the same project.
You'd only want your apps
all in the same project.
If you're splitting out your
QA from your dev versions,
you might have three
projects, each of which
has your Android app and your
iOS app and your web app in it.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: And same
thing with Analytics.
You want to share Analytics data
across Android and iOS and web
as well.
MARTIN OMANDER: Oh
right, so you can
see all the clicks in the app.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: So
you see regardless
of whether it's an
Android app or iOS app,
you share the same Analytics
store for that project.
IAN BARBER: You get
different views of it.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: Yes.
MARTIN OMANDER: So you
get different views.
IAN BARBER: Yeah, so when you go
down on the-- we have a slide,
don't we?
Shall we use the slide?
MARTIN OMANDER: Oh
yeah, could we--
IAN BARBER: Yeah, can
we get to the slides?
Can you go back to
the previous one?
MARTIN OMANDER: Show the slide
from Magnus's laptop please.
IAN BARBER: So this screen is
like what you get when you've
got a few apps connected.
This is from a real game.
And you can see there's little
Android icons because there's
a couple of Android variants.
There's little iOS icons.
Now those are
grouped effectively
by package name or bundle ID.
But they could
represent-- you could
have com.redhotlabs.bingo
dev and QA or whatever
versions of that.
That's entirely up to you.
And then if you go to the
next slide, once you click in,
you see up in the
top right there
it says iOS
com.redhotlabs.bingo.
That is for this
app, its analytics.
So we're in the project.
They all share the same project.
But we're looking at a view of
just the analytics for the iOS
app.
And you can go and see all your
active users and engagement
and all that kind of good stuff.
MARTIN OMANDER: Really
good stuff, yeah.
So this is on the project level?
IAN BARBER: Yeah, so the
Analytics, the whole dashboard
is on the project level,
the whole console.
And then within that you get a
drop down for each of the apps
so you can see the
analytics for that.
MARTIN OMANDER: Right, got it.
OK, great.
Thank you for showing us Magnus.
All right, so next
question we have
is Timur Calmatui
who is asking, what
is the best approach
to move from a SQL
based database and RESTful
API to the Firebase real time
database?
Any tips?
I struggled a bit with this too.
It's a different way of thinking
with the Realtime Database,
right?
JAMES TAMPLIN: So it is a
different way of thinking.
There's two major differences.
First of all is the
request-response nature.
Typically people think
about writing to a database
and then reading from it.
And second is the
client-server notion.
So let's take those one by one.
So the request-response,
Firebase has instead of
read and write, it has a
write and listen for changes.
So the Firebase
Realtime Database
notifies you when data changed,
and so you have a callback
and you subscribe to a
location within the database.
So a little bit of a
different mindset there.
And then second is we have
very thick client libraries.
And so one of the beautiful
things about Firebase Realtime
Database is you
don't need a server.
You can certainly access
the database from our--
we have a few, we have a Java
library and a Node library
and obviously a REST API so
you can get at it from wherever
you do HTTP.
But that's not the
recommended way of doing it.
If you use the clients'
libraries for iOS, Android,
and the web, you get
things like offline mode
where your app
remains responsive
when you don't have an
internet connection.
You get things like
transactions that we
were talking about earlier.
Those don't come
over the REST API.
And so we definitely recommend
that you use those libraries.
And then third is
the data model.
So in a SQL database,
you have tables
and you have primary
keys and foreign keys.
And the Firebase
Realtime Database
is just a large documents.
It's a large JSON object
of pretty much arbitrary
granularity.
And so the transition between
the two, the migration story
is, really think about how your
data structure needs to change.
And it will require a
pretty massive code change.
So I recommend going to
firebase.google.com/docs
and checking out the
documentation for the database.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: Exactly.
So it's not possible to find the
one-one automatic translation
script between these
two environments.
My personal suggestion
is really start
to play around with
the Firebase database
to get familiarized
with it, because it
takes a little bit
of time before you
get a feel for what the
structure's like, et cetera.
And it's a lot of fun
as well because you
get started so quickly.
And then once you've
done that, you
start to get the feel for how
to map your traditional SQL
environment over to this
kind of methodology instead.
There's also a
document of Firebase
in the documentation called
structuring data or something,
which is a great introduction
to how data is structured,
the preferred way of
doing it in Firebase.
MARTIN OMANDER: I did exactly
what you were saying Magnus.
I started playing
around with it.
And the first two days I was
playing with it, I was like,
OK, now I need to check if
this name is already taken,
OK, I'm going to
hit the database
and see if this--
no wait a minute.
That's not how it works.
I already have all the names.
If any new name is added, I will
have gotten the update already.
So I have it locally, boom.
So it was much easier, but
it took a bit of a change.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: But
when you actually
start to think about
all of the things that
are going on in the
background-- that's
why I was coming
to this database--
it's really like a real time
multinode event collaboration
technology.
There is the
database piece to it,
but the additional value that's
being created by Firebase
is to be able to create
these multinode apps that
can collaborate and
share data in real time.
It's quite amazing I think.
That was the thing that
hit me at the beginning.
I come very much from
a SQL background.
And all of this, I need
to poll the database,
I need to see if
something changes,
or I need to build a network
layer on top of the database,
so I need to have a trigger that
fires off this and then sends
some request to my server
that can up-- I mean,
the amount of logic that you
explicit;y program to create
these environments if you didn't
have the Firebase database is
so big and so complex.
And Firebase, you don't
even host the actual system
that keeps the data.
You just refer to it by URL, and
it's all automatically hosted.
And it's just working.
It's amazing I think.
JAMES TAMPLIN: Most
applications is just
a series of state changes.
And the Firebase
Realtime Database
provides you with
those state changes.
MARTIN OMANDER:
Yeah, that's right.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: Perhaps I'm
being a bit enthusiastic here,
but I'm really speaking
from my heart of using it.
I'm not trying to
sell this to people.
For me, it was a big eye opener
to start to use this API.
MARTIN OMANDER: Yeah, I agree.
And I think I started to
break out in a bit of a rash
here when you mentioned
database triggers.
And I'm feeling very
uncomfortable now.
Let's not talk about
triggers anymore, OK?
I've seen so many bugs
caused by database triggers.
It's good when state changes are
handled for you automatically.
All right, next
question we have is
from Joseph who's asking
how to do email verification
with authentication on Android.
I'm concerned about imposters.
JAMES TAMPLIN:
I'll take that one.
So one of the exciting new
features in the announcement
last week is email verification.
So before, Firebase
Auth had password reset.
And we've added
email verification
as of last Wednesday.
So it's in the Firebase
Console under the Auth tab.
And if you under the Auth
tab, the last top tab
has all of your email
templates in there.
So there's password resets and
there's email verification.
And I think there's one
or two others actually.
And so you can go in there
and you can customize it
to your heart's
content, whatever
text you want to put in there.
And we'll provide a URL
that users can click and can
hit and verify their email.
MARTIN OMANDER: And just
to back up and explain
what this feature is, this
is the feature where--
or maybe James you could just
describe the user experience
as they go through the flow?
JAMES TAMPLIN: Yeah, so this is,
if you've ever signed up for,
pick your SaaS provider here,
what it'll say is great.
You've signed up.
Please go and check your
email and verify your email.
And you'll go over to
your email provider,
and it'll say thank
you for signing up.
Please click this
link to confirm.
And there's a bunch of security
benefits to doing this.
One, ensuring that
if you're actually
using your email
for your username,
that that is actually your
username or your email.
And so you'll click that
link and it'll say verified.
And then it'll let you go
ahead and use the application.
MARTIN OMANDER: So
this is a piece of code
that I've written
many, many times,
I think once for ever app.
So I don't need to
write code to have this
in my Firebase [INAUDIBLE].
JAMES TAMPLIN: Correct,
this is all out the box.
MARTIN OMANDER: Nice.
I didn't know that.
Cool, thank you, James.
IAN BARBER: I was
going to say, because I
see the giant hook coming out.
we've got no more
questions coming up.
But there was one that
came out on Twitter
just at the end which was
what's the best way for people
to stay up to date other than
just staying on the Hangout
with us for the rest of time,
which I think is probably--
MARTIN OMANDER: Which
would be pretty awesome.
IAN BARBER: It's
not going to scale.
MARTIN OMANDER: Yeah,
it's not going to scale.
IAN BARBER: James, what's
your preferred choice?
JAMES TAMPLIN: My
preferred choice
of how to stay in touch
with us, so there's
a few channels you have.
First of all, I'd
recommend Twitter.
So we're just
@Firebase on Twitter.
Super active there
and you'll get links
to the latest releases
and blog posts
that we put off and events
that we'll be attending.
So that's a really great one.
If you're looking for
something more interactive
and you want to chat with the
team, we have our mailing list.
So it's
groups.google.com/firebase-dash.
And you can go in
there and if you
want to share with the
community something
that you've built using
Firebase or if you're
looking for some feedback
or something like that,
you're more than
welcome to join.
We've built a really
robust community
and a passionate
community there,
and we'd love to have
you be a part of that.
The third way, if you
have a technical question,
so if you have a question on
implementation or something
that involves code,
Stack Overflow
is the place you want to go.
So we've got a lot of the team
members who are active there.
And again, we have a
fantastic community.
So if you want to up
your Stack Overflow rep,
please help out there as well.
That would fantastic.
As Ian mentioned, some
things don't scale.
So do love your
help where possible.
You're welcome to
participate on GitHub.
We've got a lot of open source
projects-- AngularFire 2,
and we've got one
called GeoFire to help
you deal with geolocation
in your applications.
IAN BARBER: FirebaseUI.
JAMES TAMPLIN: We've
got FirebaseUI,
so we've got FirebaseUI is--
IAN BARBER: New job
dispatcher, that's in there.
That's pretty bad ass.
JAMES TAMPLIN:
Lots of good stuff.
And then--
IAN BARBER: Blog.
JAMES TAMPLIN: And then the
final way's the blog, yeah.
MARTIN OMANDER: The blog--
where does the blog live?
JAMES TAMPLIN: So
firebase.google.com/blog
or-- yeah, that's the quickest
way, firebase.google.com/blog.
MARTIN OMANDER: Good stuff.
Lots of resources, good stuff.
Magnus, Ian, are either
of you responding
to questions on Stack Overflow?
IAN BARBER: Yep.
MARTIN OMANDER: I think I
remember reading one of your--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
IAN BARBER: You'll
see a lot of the team.
You'll see names like puf
and Abe and Kato, myself.
There's a whole bunch of
the Firebase dev rel team
that are on there.
CodingDoug, he's on
there quite a bit.
You're going to give a
lot of people on there.
And we're always happy
to answer questions,
but yeah, as James
said, we're even happier
to upvote your answers.
We like that.
JAMES TAMPLIN: And really
interacting with the community
is one of the things that is
sort of imbued in the culture.
And as we talked about
earlier, this test and iterate,
we are going to build a
better product by getting
your input and your feedback.
And it's been
fantastic to hear some
of the questions and
feature requests come
through here today.
But we'd love more of those.
So if you actually go
to firebase.google.com
and you click Support
up on the top,
you can actually submit
feature requests there.
And as we go through the
product roadmapping process,
those get taken into account.
And we'd love to
hear your thoughts,
and obviously participate
in the different channels.
And we're excited to
hear what you've built.
IAN BARBER: Yeah, that
support place is really worth
knowing about that.
You can send feature
requests and bugs there,
and you can also get
troubleshooting support.
And that's not going
into a black hole.
We have a team, some here.
We have a team in Manila.
And they are responding
to it all through the day.
And they've done
a fantastic job.
So if you have a
problem, they're
going to be a great place to go.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN:
And in that place,
you can also see the other
reference like Stack Overflow
and other groups, et cetera.
MARTIN OMANDER: Oh, OK,
so the one stop shop is
firebase.google.com/support.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: There
you'll see all the--
MARTIN OMANDER: And there's
your-- ah, very good.
IAN BARBER: That's
the quick answer.
[LAUGHTER]
MARTIN OMANDER: This is good.
This is good.
And I'm happy you guys told me
about all these new features,
or I would have been in their
clicking on support asking you,
the email notification?
Oh, it's already in there.
I've learned a lot here guys.
Thank you very much
Ian, Magnus, James.
A lot of cool features that I'm
going to implement in my game.
And it'll be great fun.
And thank you very
much for posting
all your great questions to us.
We really enjoyed doing
this interactively with you.
And so these new Firebase
tools, as we heard,
are available as of last week.
And you can get a head
start on your competition
by going to
firebase.google.com and start
using the tools today.
Also be on the lookout this
fall for local Firebase events
in your local community run
by Google Developer groups.
In the summer and
in the fall, they
will run Firebase themed events.
Thank you for joining us.
And remember, you developers
are building the future.
That is an awesome
responsibility.
And we can't wait to
see what you build.
Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]